we love you Eugene oh and boy after no
UFC gym see yours out late I know where
I'm going today we are here at a USC gym
to meet some professional UFC fighters
and fight each other I have no fighting
experience I got punched in the nose
once in fifth grade I've heard someone's
feelings
apparently Eugene has trained in martial
arts that's not fair
I feel like Zack might squeal like a
little piggy and it really excites me if
nobody gets hurt that's a miracle what I
know about you have see people of all
kinds of fighting backgrounds come into
an octagon and they hang out for three
minutes or so when I watch it on YouTube
it gets me going oh yeah if I'm gonna be
beat up by anybody it might as well be a
UFC champion right Chuck the Iceman
Liddell former UFC light heavyweight
champ USC broke on the scene in 1993
just a way to battle different styles
against each other what we found out is
the best style the combination is
putting them all together when you reach
the UFC you're the top of the top I feel
like it's the true physical and mental
game of chess kicking asses what I do
for a living people like to watch other
people fight for us but how can we
possibly do well at this I mean I'm
looking at you guys have the body of a
guide give me an I Cupid leg Zeus maybe
you're Zeus my ma'am is gonna be booth
when I'd get ready for a fight or when
I'm walking to the cage I don't think
about anything I just know I got
somebody I got a beat up just gets in
yeah I'm liking just the fight what's
the worst that can happen I can think of
some pretty bad things that can happen
are you guys scared to get hit
absolutely not punch people I don't
punch them just to give him a little
love tap back oh my god man I punch him
I'm actually trying to hurt them with
every single bit of my soul yeah
1 2 percentage-wise strength what are
you at right now 10 gonna go 250 I could
but I don't wanna break your shoulder
anyway whereas we all kick Zach real
quick and you're back I'm back boom
so first and foremost tell us how you
got into the sport I went to college I
play soccer and I hated it was in high
school wrestling college yeah soccer
just wasn't violent enough think it was
like the first time I ever knocked a
goalie down I was like wait a minute you
know they're getting a good workout they
can defend themselves on the streets I
was like I'm gonna give this a shot and
just from day one I just fell in love
with it a guy saw me he goes hey you I'm
gonna hide you mixed martial arts I said
sure why not and so I take classes and
that's how it began I come here look the
arm up go to eat the Frog yeah I hate
their sight
do you think it's going to be really
easy a really hard to take down somebody
as strong as me ah very easy actually
I'm brain just [ __ ] amateur hour
right now
it is definitely amateur hour it's
always better to make somebody give up
and tap out because it's like [ __ ] you
got me and you go here you want to
massage the Achilles tendon and we have
it you go here so much now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take this foot and
put it in my armpit and I'm going here
and I'm gonna fall down like this
what's your tactic I would take it
somewhere to where the other person is
not good so when you're here he is
objective it's the posture up and I can
jump up here I do not endorse this at
all okay this right here I do not
endorse on the flip side what was your
worst personal injury I got cut and it
was probably started from Mike here all
the way down to my cheek I broke my rib
in a Muay Thai fight had my eyeball
split open oh and I remember walking
back to the corner it would just pop in
and out and I just lay and when I
breathe up like and his finger went
right in my eye yeah they show the
replay and you can see where the guy's
finger goes missing in my what's the
worst injury you've ever had I got my
penis caught in my zipper Oh fine that's
that smokes at all
I don't know if I've ever met anyone
who's a champion of anything don't let
me Tim date you come on just like that I
actually have a broken pinkie right now
that's pretty big I figure I can dance
around I can kick a lot first kick we're
going to do is a real basic muy Thai
kick
I got step out on an angle which opens
up my hips to turn my body oh there's no
jumping kicks yeah you do double kick my
wife really didn't want me to do this
Sunday she cares for you yeah that's
nice my wife would probably make me do
this just to so I feel pain grab the
neck Oh God
I'm ice and tire you can shake him a
little girl it comes down to who's
smarter it's all about deception your
wife no I did yeah all right there you
go I got thrown around like a rag doll
what do you think is a really big
misconception about UFC especially when
we came in everyone thought we were in
watching the end result at the top of
the game you know I don't really I have
never met a guy who's a dumb guy I mean
I have a green accounting profession you
know they expect us to be mean I mean
they realized I couldn't store more
people like you seem like a cool down
there yeah what do I like that I got to
go to the movies with you I got to move
with you to what you want to I'm a
normal person I just like fighting an
octagon in front of thousands of people
who wouldn't Jessica
every fight starts standing up near that
Bell we come out swinging oh the
wonderful champ Ronda Rousey loves to do
throws oh we're gonna do a counter to a
throw okay so as you try to throw me
this way I'm in a backdrop oh you see
that move you catch I'll do it again
oh so you're using momentum as soon as
they try to pull you over you fall with
that's beautiful look at your indomina
position right there for judging I grab
it here oh oh oh now once I got you here
I'm gonna keep you there and I'm just
gonna punch him straight yeah this is
called ground and pound Brandon yeah if
I'm the one on the cage instead I'm
gonna fish it up this way oh they make
this bone right here for that face lock
beautiful perfect but today Chuck and
Jess guy are gonna officiate our match
well I'm hoping we don't have to laugh
at you too much no matter who I fight at
best I'm 40 pounds lighter than that
feel like Jean would laugh at me a lot I
would hold back against Ned's right
pinky everything else is fair game
BAM one pop in the nose and he's gonna
be like whoa whoa whoa if he's gonna put
me in holds I'm gonna fart gonna fart my
way out of the situation I don't want to
hurt any of these people I love these
guys I don't want to hurt them and I
don't want them to hurt me I'm gonna be
fighting teeth because we're both the
jet list and I'll fight Ned because
we're both the most aggressive I don't
think that's gonna work for me he's way
too big for you oh so we have to go by
weight class we're gonna fight him no
and you're gonna fight him that's right
it didn't look [ __ ] or are you gonna
fight me squirrel versus great white
tree today we are in this octagon to
fight for one three-minute round I'm
fighting Ned great I get the one whose
webs off adrenaline I love you that
first punch is gonna come out
fight on and
I'm gonna be like ah get his night like
the squirrel that he shouldn't fall down
with his finger and I shouldn't fall
down cuz I'm tall I felt like I was
outsmarting Keith I knew he was so tall
at if I got lower than him I could flip
him over
grab the dog puts his head down there
you go it's really exhausting it takes
so much your body work once you're on
the ground you got it Oh so as soon as I
got a net in a headlock I'm like you
know what Ned can do minimal damage from
this point they're just hugging that is
a really intense three minutes it goes
so fast when you see it on TV
I don't want fighters up above me and
Chuck bolt can agree on a winner here
scoring wins but I know
we have swagger vs. quiver we are here
today to fight to the death
okay what I think I'll easily be able to
find a point where he's gonna destroy
himself fighter are you ready
Oh didn't come here to fight Eugene he's
[ __ ] crazy
some reason he wants to hurt me oh I
come from a striking background so I'm
gonna try to improve some my wrestling
and grappling techniques I landed some
pretty solid punches on Eugene's
beautiful beautiful face it's gonna be
wrong
he beat the [ __ ] out of me get up let's
get up he got me to the ground several
times about like a minute in my body
just quit on me oh my god what is this
it was kind of fun until I got punched
and knocked down and everything not
sucked I haterade I never won dudes
again now kiss I'm like you mean it
that was embarrassing for you we declare
our winner swagger okay
I honestly have been really afraid of
fighting but in this environment this is
awesome like this is a great way to like
train and workout I feel like I was able
to link up everything we learned today
it felt a little savage but I feel like
I got Val greater appreciation of all
the strategy that goes into it I'm
exhausted
I'm dizzy pretty nauseous actually
that's what a concussion feels like I
think UFC has a new fan now I'm
definitely gonna start following it
we're here what are we doing we're going
to fight at the Staples Center it's time
to watch people feel each other oh we
have to cross
guys
nice job